>>> Ladies and gentlemen, please welcome vice
president of engineering for Google, Vic Gundotra.
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Well, good morning, everybody.
You made it, even at this early hour.
I hope you enjoyed that party last night.
How --
[ Applause ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Yeah?
How about that spider?
Was that cool or what?
After a few drinks, I thought that thing was
going to chase me.
A lot of fun.
Let me also welcome the many thousands who
are watching our live stream on YouTube.
Yesterday, just for your information, we had
over 24,000 people watching it concurrently
live.
So in addition to the 5,000-plus folks we
had here, we had almost 30,000 watch us yesterday.
So welcome to everyone watching on YouTube.
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: To begin today's keynote,
I'd like to start with a story.
It's a story of my very first day on the job
at Google.
Now, I'm sure you've all been at a new job.
You understand the apprehensiveness you might
feel with a new office, new people.
It was on that very first day that I met a
man named Mr. Andy Rubin.
Now, I suspect most of you know who Andy Rubin
is.
At the time, he was responsible for what was
then a secret project code-named "Android."
And on that first day, Andy enthusiastically
described to me the team's mission and purpose.
And as he spoke, I'll level with you, I was
skeptical.
In fact, I interrupted Andy.
And I said, "Andy, I don't get it.
Does the world really need another mobile
operating system?
Google's about advertising.
Shouldn't we be on every phone?"
To this day, I remember Andy's response.
And he made two points.
The first point Andy made was that it was
critically important to provide a free mobile
operating system, an open source operating
system, that would enable innovation at every
level of the stack.
In other words, OEMs should be free to build
all kinds of devices, devices with keyboards,
without keyboards, with front-facing cameras,
two inches, three inches, four inches, that
operators should be able to compete on the
strength and coverage of their network, 2G,
3G, 4G, LTP, CDMA.
And that in the end, with innovation coming
at every layer, it would be the consumer who
would be able to benefit by getting the best
device and best network for them.
I remember Andy's second point.
He argued that if Google did not act, we faced
a Draconian future, a future where one man,
one company, one device, one carrier would
be our only choice.
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: That's a future we don't want.
So if you believe in openness, if you believe
in choice, if you believe in innovation from
everyone, then welcome to Android.
Now, let's get started.
Let's talk a little bit about the momentum
that we've achieved in 18 months.
It's been a year and a half since we've started
with Android.
How are we doing?
Let's do a little bit of a report card.
First of all, let's demonstrate some momentum.
It's hard to believe that in only 18 months,
we've achieved over 60 compatible devices,
where your software, where your applications
can run.
And these devices are not just from, you know,
people you haven't heard of.
These are from the leading consumer electronic
companies in the world, Sony Ericsson, HTC,
Motorola, and many others, who are producing
devices that meet the needs of consumers.
We think this is pretty fantastic progress
in just 18 months.
Of course, it's not just the creation of the
devices.
It's the 21 OEMs in 48 countries and over
59 carriers who have joined the Android revolution.
Of course, producing devices, making them
available across a multitude of countries
and carriers doesn't necessarily mean that
we're going to see adoption.
Have users found Android to be something that
they desire?
Well, last year, we reported, late last year,
that we had reached a sales run rate, a daily
activation rate, of over 30,000 units a day.
In February, just a few months later, we announced
that our daily run rate had achieved 60,000
units a day.
I'm very proud to announce today that our
run rate daily activations has now passed
100,000 a day.
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Go, Android!
Of course, that momentum has led to some pretty
significant milestones.
One of the ones we are most proud of is that
this quarter, we are now second in the United
States in smartphone sales, second only to
RIM.
And that's pretty amazing progress in 18 months.
We're second in smartphone sales, but according
to AdMob data, we are now first this quarter
in total Web and app usage.
That's fantastic.
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: You know, we set a crazy internal
milestone for ourselves.
The phones are being used by consumers, but
what are they being used for?
And we set a crazy internal goal when we shipped
turn-by-turn navigation for Android.
We thought it might be possible to have a
half a billion miles navigated in the first
year.
In hardly six months, we've now crossed a
billion miles navigated with turn-by-turn
navigation on Android.
So users just love that feature.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: There are some who say that
users don't use Google Search on smartphones.
Well, we're a company driven by data, not
by opinions.
And you know what the data shows?
The data shows that we've seen a 5X growth
in the past two years.
That's not just on Android, but that's across
all smartphone categories.
People love Google search.
You give them a great browser, and they do
Google search, tremendous, awesome usage of
the Web on these devices.
Of course, what they love is applications.
And today I'm happy to announce that we've
crossed 50,000 applications in the Android
Marketplace.
And, really, the credit there goes to you.
Thank you, for the 180,000 developers.
Thank you.
The 180,000 developers who have joined the
Android revolution.
Really, it's your hard work that's paired
with the innovation that's coming from OEMs
and carriers that makes the mobile ecosystem
work.
We certainly couldn't have done this without
you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you for supporting
Android.
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Now, let's talk about the
platform.
We've finished the section on momentum.
Let's talk about what we're doing to make
the Android platform continue to evolve and
get better.
In this section, I have over 20 demos, 22
demos, I believe.
In order to help me with that, I'd like to
invite up on stage Matt Waddell, my partner
in crime here.
Many of you may remember Matt from last year.
And we're going to go through a number of
demos that are going to really showcase what
we're doing with Android.
There are five major areas of investments
that we're making in the platform.
Now, we've been quick to iterate with Android.
In fact, there's been seven releases in those
18 months.
And today we're announcing the next release,
Android 2.2 code-named Froyo.
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: What's in Froyo?
Let's talk about five pillars.
Number one, let's begin with speed.
Now, as you developers know, the Android architecture
is one that's built upon a virtual machine,
the Dalvik virtual machine.
We think it's important.
It's a critical design decision that we made
that future-proofs your application.
We have big dreams for Android.
And part of those dreams mean that Android
will go to new places with new chip architectures.
But by having your applications write to the
virtual machine, we believe we can carry the
entire ecosystem to exciting new areas.
Of course, that only works if the virtual
machine is fast and the Dalvik VM has done
its job being fast, efficient, and automatic
and easy for developers.
But we can do even better.
We're very proud to announce that in Froyo,
we've added a JIT, a just-in-time compiler,
this gives up to two to five X speedup of
your apps on the exact same hardware.
Now, this is best demonstrated.
And let's do that.
Let's go to our first demo.
We're going to show you a game.
The game has been modified for purposes of
this demo.
You guys may know Replica Island.
Here's what we've done to modify the game.
The game now will show the frame rate that
it's rendering in the bottom right-hand corner.
If the frame rate drops beneath 30 frames
a second, the screen will Flash red.
Exact same hardware, exact same game, top
is running Froyo with JIT compilation, the
bottom is running Eclair.
We're going to introduce a crazy number of
monsters into this game.
You see the monsters keep getting added, increasing
the complexity.
You see the frame rate at the top.
As we add complexity, it starts to slow down.
You'll note there at the bottom, there are
times when we're dropping beneath 30 frame
a second and it's flashing red.
You'll note at the top, with Froyo, exactly
the same game runs much better, never dropping
beneath 30 frames a second, all because of
the JIT compiler.
All right.
Let's go back to slides.
[ Applause ]